tudo começou para mim quando me dei
conta que o meu judaísmo estava ligado à
comida que tinha na minha casa todos os
dias e é basicamente uma comida a
judaicas e fará de eu não sabia que o
judaísmo estava na comida até que a
minha avó do e seu eu percebi que com
ela o meu judaísmo junto minha voz tinha
vindo da turquia e fazia aqui no brasil
a comida que ela comia na casa dela no
país de origem
ela me ensinado pra minha mãe essa
comida e essa e isso era o que tinha na
nossa mesa no cotidiano
eu não tinha aprendido a fazer a comida
judaica separar dele aliás ninguém na
minha geração sabia fazer a comida das
avós na minha família e eu acabei então
a me reunindo com a minha mãe e minha
tia nós escrevemos as receitas e eu fiz
um livrinho bem simples e daí para todas
as pessoas até à quarta geração que na
época eram bebês
um pouco depois disso um bistrô me
chamou para fazer uma pesquisa eles
queriam conhecer o que as pessoas
achavam da comida e do lugar
eu aprendi que a comida afetava eles de
maneira muito profunda significava
coisas muito importantes
me diziam assim a gente come no lugar
com mofo e aquilo não agride ou então a
gente como é que uma das comidas que a
gente nunca mais esquece
uma pessoa me disse eu vou mostrar no
céu
esse é o lustre que tinha no lugar
a comida tem uma dimensão comunicativa
ela manifesta significados e com base
nisso eu adorei a idéia de que a comida
a comida é uma narrativa ela pode ser
uma forma social de contar histórias
nos dias de hoje na vida que a gente tem
a comida como um espaço de saberes
sociais ea refeição comum
um pouco de sociabilidade e empobreceram
perderam na condição simbólica na
comissão afetiva na condição social
a gente comer uma comida que a gente não
sabe de onde vem
dificilmente as pessoas têm tempo ou
energia para ir para a cozinha preparar
uma refeição pessoas não sentamos juntos
à mesa para comer quando os então não
conversam cada um na sua telinha
vocês já devem ter tido esse tipo de
experiência pelo menos ter visto que não
vivenciaram então a sociabilidade que é
tá na essência da comida tá escorregadia
tá fugir dia e é nesse contexto que a
comida do mário a comida no bistrô ea
comida no restaurante mínimo reagem e
mostram que existem âncoras e é sobre
elas que eu quero falar pra vocês três
comidas e o amor
são três histórias têm diferenças mas
tem uma coisa muito importante em comum
a primeira é a história da comida do
mário
a comida do mário é uma comida de
cozinheiro não porque falta o requinte
dos chefes mas porque ela é feita de um
jeito diferente ela vem a mesas
carregadinha de amor pleno em
generosidade em carinho em humor e uma
área às vezes nem sabe quem vai comer
ele imagina as sensações e os
pensamentos das pessoas vai para a
cozinha e prepara um dia ele foi no
bistrô
nesse mesmo bistrô onde fiz a pesquisa
onde ele costumava cozinhar as quartas à
noite e eventualmente nos almoços de
sábado e ele preparou uma comida para
duas pessoas que ele sabia que
adiantariam lá ele cozinhou só para as
duas pessoas
ele mesmo não ficou para jantar e deixou
comida de presente de aniversário para
uma delas
e quando ele estava no trabalho ele
pegou uma folha de rascunho qualquer
como a gente faz em casa né rabiscou uma
idéia
no mas acabou fazendo uma fazendo uma
coisa um pouco diferente
como costuma acontecer com quem cozinha
ele fez uma terrine de berinjelas com
pimentões queijo de cabra uma salada com
vinagrete de menta aromatizado com alho
o prato principal era um salmão com
molho de massa verde e vinho tinha uma
surpresa de gengibre em algum lugar
daqueles salmão e acompanhava um arroz
com abobrinhas revogadas e para
sobremesa ele fez uma torta de frutas e
aniversariante era eu
imaginem a minha emoção a minha
felicidade ea minha gratidão
quando eu cheguei pra jantar e recebia
aquele mundo de doação no prato
um pouco depois além disso romário foi
na casa de uma amiga que estava doente
na alma e ele fez pra ela uma comida
clara e sim sem expectativas era ravióli
de queijo com molho branco liso bem
suave e ele serviu pra ela no pratinho
fundo de porcelana branca como eu com
ela de colher
eles tomaram água e conversaram tão
fraco e assim ele confortou amiga a
comida do mário é uma comida de quem
gosta muito de dar e não se importa se
não receber
ela é uma comida de cozinha de casa de
cozinha que tem história que importa
o mário não tem restaurante ele faz
outra coisa para viver
ele cozinha para a família e cozinha
para os amigos
ele cozinha por eles a outra história a
história da comida no bistrô a comida
num bistrô assim como a comida do mário
é uma comida de cozinheiro
era um lugar bem pequeno que servia
poucas mesas
os clientes eram sempre os mesmos e nem
a equipe que trabalhava lá tinha
treinamento profissional e ali se
estabelecesse um cotidiano afetivo quase
familiar porque as pessoas vão sempre
todos os dias sempre as mesmas e os
garçons e garçonetes tinha uma relação
de relativa proximidade com os clientes
a conheciam ele pelo nome e até ligavam
para dizer quando tinha uma comida que
eles gostavam desligado a dizer lá oiac
hoje a gente está fazendo uma comida que
tu gostas idéia vem que passa pra comer
com a gente tudo era feito com muita
delicadeza não havia pressão
esse lugar tinha uma decoração muito
inusual era extremamente criativo e os
enfeites os bebê los vasos de flores os
quadros trocavam de lugar toda hora
quase todo dia então um dia tinha um
quadro uma parede no outro dia o mesmo
quando estava na outra parede isso
acontecer com todos os objetos os
clientes achavam isso muito interessante
porque dentro daquela rotina que eles
estabeleceram ali havia sempre o
inesperado
a cozinha é preparava a comida pensando
em quem é comer então tinha um cliente
que dizia quero ouvir em cima outro
dizia quero ouvir em baixo ea cozinha
fazia isso com muita alegria
um dia um prato do menu era o risoto que
cada cliente quisesse comer cada um
imagina um risoto ea cozinha preparou um
diferente para cada onça imaginem a
trabalheira que é isso para uma cozinha
de um gestor bistrô pequeno onde ninguém
tem treinamento profissional mas eles
faziam isso com muita alegria
numa outra situação um cliente pediu eu
quero a metade da metade da fatia de
bolo mousse de chocolate com a metade da
metade da bola de sorvete de creme com
amêndoas e o garçom olho para eles sinto
me deu esse quadro
numa outra situação um uma outra pessoa
pediu eu quero uma porção soft farta da
torta ele estava de dieta mas não queria
privação
todas essas situações eram levadas com
muita alegria com muito bom humor porque
trabalhava
as comidas esse lugar era inusuais
decoração para a cultura a culinária da
época né
eles serviram beterrabas carameladas
serviram o pepino japonês na manteiga e
as pessoas adoravam serviram um peito de
frango embrulhado num crepe com molho de
chocolate e pimenta e canela sorvete de
gengibre
as pessoas gostavam muito disso e me
diziam as comidas aqui são inteligentes
em seu lugar criou os almoços de sábado
que é um evento muito festivos e nessas
ocasiões eles convidavam alguém que
gostasse de cozinhar para criar um menu
e preparar a comida para todos os
clientes
depois a pessoa embora não precisava
arcar com os encargos administrativos né
era basicamente brincar de restaurante
os clientes recebiam tanta coisa lá e
coisas tão importantes que eles não
queriam pagar eles achavam que não dava
pra misturar tudo isso que era muito bom
com dinheiro e eles preferiam anotar os
gastos no caderninho e acertar no fim do
mês ou até receber uma fatura mensal em
casa
a essência da comida no bistrô era vida
toda a comida da vida mas junto com ela
era o amor à beleza à dedicação e à
brincadeira prazerosa entre a rotina eo
inesperado
a pessoa que tinha concebido aquele
lugar uma cozinheira ela achava que os
restaurantes eram muito formais e
uniformes e ela tinha imaginado que no
dela
os garçons e garçonetes servir os
clientes dançando porque para ela a
comida é magia amor e encantamento
esse era um bebezinho que trocava de
lugar
todo dia lá na ocasião dessa pesquisa um
cliente me disse a boca não é uma
catacumba ea outra história é história
do restaurante mínimo
o restaurante mínimo é o restaurante de
uma mesa só e de um homem só o senhor
enzo em seu nome fictício está o senhor
enzo era o proprietário o gerente
o cozinheiro o garçom e segurança ea
mesa de refeições era na casa dele eu
fui jantar lá com um grupo ea pessoa que
fez a reserva contou que foram inúmeros
telefonemas até que ele tivesse esse
certificado de que tinha ajustado o menu
de forma que todos fossem ficar
satisfeitos
eu gosto de cada um quando nós chegamos
lá a gente foi para a sala de estar dele
e o senhor enzo com gestos quase de um
profissional ea servindo os aperitivos
uma pessoa que estava conosco reparou
que tinha uma parede laranja e ele disse
laranja abriu o apetite quando o senhor
endo certificou que estava todo mundo
bem servido ele veio pra sala sentou
conosco e começou a conversar
ele contou alguma coisa sobre a cidade
onde ele gostava de passear ea rua e ele
preferia na itália depois ele comentou
sobre o livro que estava lendo fez um
comentário sobre a guerra civil
espanhola e contou uma história de
comida
ele disse que na noite anterior ao nosso
jantar ele tinha experimentado uma
receita nova que levava amêndoas
cortadas finíssimas mas que ele não ia
oferecer essa sobremesa para nós porque
as amêndoas que ele tinha encontrado era
um finas
nesse momento ele fez
vence o profundo e depois em voz grave
ele disse é uma responsabilidade dar de
comer alguém ele contou então que até os
66 anos não sabia fazer um ovo ele comia
comida da mãe e ele um dia se perguntou
como é que eu vou fazer pra comer o
risoto de funghi da minha mãe quando ela
não estiver mais aqui
ele pediu que ela ensinar se ele é
cozinhar ela não ensinou mas deixou que
ele observasse cozinhava junto uma
funcionária mas os senhores achava que a
comida dela não era comanda a mãe um dia
a mãe se foi e ele começou a cozinhar um
dia funcionária se foi
eles seguiam cozinhando
ele contou então que vivia de uma
aposentadoria que era insuficiente e que
para aumentar a renda
ele decidiu abrir a casa dele como
restaurante de uma mesa só nesse momento
ele se retirou foi para a cozinha
finalizar o jantar e convidou pra que a
gente passasse para a sala onde ele
serviria
quando nós chegamos ali se criou uma
situação muito difícil porque ninguém
conseguia sentar à mesa afinal era a
mesa da casa dele a gente aguardava que
ele indicar seus lugares mas ele não fez
isso e eu observei que todas as paredes
ali era um laranja
em uma delas tinha uma pintura com uma
fisionomia era a mãe dele durante todo
aquele jantar eu fiquei me perguntando
afinal quem dá de comer aquela era uma
comida com história e o sentido daquela
comida era o da doação de um bem amoroso
que tinha sido dado ao senhor enzo pela
mãe e que ele generosamente repartir
conosco distribuir para nós essas três
histórias de realidade são da minha
vivência na pesquisa do tema comida à
sociedade
elas são singulares mas ao mesmo tempo
tem a pluralidade de introduzir muitas
outras
de comida nenhuma celebridade essas
histórias são as histórias de muita
gente de muitos de vocês
elas ensinam que é tempo de parar que a
hospitalidade em espaço público é
possível
elas resgatam a associação entre
nutrição e afeto
a generosidade o respeito ao gosto de
cada um
o tempo do convívio a beleza ea
possibilidade de transformação no
anonimato dessas cozinhas mostram que
cozinhar e oferecer comida
são atividades significativas de amor e
doação
eu acho que nós alimentamos o futuro com
narrativas de comida de todo dia como
estas
esse é o fogão da minha casa na época em
que eu nasci onde era feita a comida que
me deu meu judaísmo
muito obrigado